[Música]
se conocieron las declaraciones de
impuestos del expresidente de Estados
Unidos Donald Trump el congreso publicó
casi 6.000 páginas con los datos de
entre 2015 y 2020 El Magnate minimizó la
importancia de la publicación
pese a haber intentado bloquearla en la
Corte Suprema
al gobierno de izquierda de chile
indultó a 12 personas condenadas por las
protestas de 2019 así como a uno de los
miembros más reconocidos del grupo
armado que combatió a la dictadura
militar de Augusto pinochet
parlamentarios opositores rechazan la
medida Tenemos reporte desde Santiago
el presidente de Brasil Yair bolsonaro
salió del país con rumbo Estados Unidos
y no estará presente la investidura de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva antes de esto
apoyó las manifestaciones de grupos de
extrema derecha pero se desmarcó de los
hechos violentos Tenemos también reporte
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos en Estados Unidos
porque a pocos días de que los
republicanos se hagan cargo de la cámara
de representantes un comité demócrata
hizo públicos miles de documentos con
los datos Fiscales y tributarios de la
expresidente Donald Trump los papeles
demuestran que el republicano no pagó
ningún impuesto en 2020 año de su salida
presidencial y que sus impuestos no
fueron debidamente auditados Marina
sardinha con los detalles
La última carta antes de perder la
mayoría en la cámara de representantes
el comité de medios y arbitrios de la
cámara baja estadounidense publicó las
declaraciones de los impuestos del
expresidente Donald Trump de 2015 a 2020
pese a la larga batalla legal del
republicano para impedir que vieran la
luz la comisión publicó miles de páginas
de los documentos Fiscales que podrían
ser investigados por periodistas y
expertos independientes un presidente no
es un contribuyente ordinario tiene
poder e influencia A diferencia de
cualquier otro estadounidense y un gran
poder conlleva una responsabilidad aún
mayor análisis preliminares mostraron
que en Trump declaró grandes pérdidas en
sus negocios para pagar casi nada en
impuestos durante años llegando a no
pagar en absoluto en 2020 antes de su
salida de la presidencia el comité
demócrata detrás de la publicación No
solo Busca responsabilizar a Trump sino
también al servicio de impuestos interno
al que señalan de no auditar
correctamente al expresidente Trump
rompió con el presidente al convertirse
en el primer aspirante a la casa blanca
y luego presidente en mantener sus decla
de las Sombras sirven para los
demócratas la publicación es cuestión de
transparencia los republicanos alegan un
peligroso precedente al erosionar la
privacidad fiscal de los ciudadanos el
republicano le restó importancia a la
publicación
aunque estas declaraciones de impuestos
contienen relativamente poca información
y no información que casi cualquiera
puede entender son extremadamente
complejas el comportamiento de los
demócratas radicales es una vergüenza
para el congreso de Estados Unidos
en septiembre de 2020 el New York Times
publicó en exclusiva un reporte
demostrando que Trump no pago impuestos
sobre la renta en diez de los 15 años
anteriores a su llegada a la casa blanca
la revelaciones suponen un nuevo golpe
al ex mandatario que busca regresar a la
Casa Blanca en 2024
Finalizó el gobierno interino de
Venezuela que desde 2019 tenía a Juan
guaidó como líder de esta institución
reconocida por Estados Unidos y cerca de
50 países una mayoría de 72 exdiputados
de los que entonces votaron a favor de
crear este testamento aprobaron este
viernes su eliminación tan solo 23
diputados de esta administración
interina sin poder real dentro de
Venezuela entre ellos Juan guaidó
votaron a favor de mantenerlo nuestra
corresponsal en Venezuela Daniela
Zambrano tiene los detalles
una sesión que se extendió por más de
siete horas que culminó con 72 votos a
favor 29 en contra y ocho abstenciones
para dar fin a la figura del gobierno
interino que presidió Juan guaidó
Durante los últimos cuatro años quienes
votaron en contra aseguran que se está
poniendo en riesgo los activos de
Venezuela en el exterior y algunos lo
calificaron Incluso como un salto al
vacío y un suicidio político quienes
votaron a favor de que finalizara la
figura del interinato aseguran que esto
no es así que por el contrario se está
creando una comisión de la asamblea
nacional precisamente para proteger
estos activos en el exterior también se
decidió prolongar por un año más la
vigencia de la asamblea nacional electa
en el año 2015 recordemos que en las
últimas elecciones parlamentarias Fueron
consideradas inconstitucionales por la
oposición sin embargo está esa asamblea
vigente que es la que preside Jorge
Rodríguez dirigente del oficialismo una
acalorado debate en el cual quedó
evidenciada una vez más las rupturas
dentro de la oposición que Juan guaidó
finalizó diciendo que se estaba
entregando una herramienta de lucha
contra la dictadura
y este año 2022 termina convulso en
Bolivia especialmente en la región de
Santa Cruz su gobernador Luis Fernando
Camacho deberá permanecer bajo la medida
de prisión preventiva por cuatro meses
luego de que fuera vinculado al proceso
denominado golpe de estado 1 decisión
que obtuvo como respuesta un paro de 24
horas en las calles de Santa Cruz de la
Sierra
vamos a Chile en donde el presidente
Gabriel boric concedió un indulto a 12
manifestantes que habían sido condenados
por las protestas sociales de 2019
también hizo lo propio con uno de los
miembros del grupo armado frente
patriótico Manuel Rodríguez que luchó
contra La dictadura militar de Augusto
pinochet En las décadas del 70 al 90
previamente nuestra corresponsal en
Santiago Patricia Luna nos contó qué
originó la decisión Del ejecutivo y sus
primeras reacciones
el presidente Gabriel cumplió este
viernes con una de sus más antiguas y
también polémicas
promesas de campaña al finalmente
indultó a 12
personas condenadas por
delitos vinculados al estallido social
en una decisión muy polémica sobre todo
por los sectores de la derecha del país
que han criticado la medida como
inaceptable y preocupante y han tomado
medidas como retirarse de un acuerdo de
que se estaba negociando entre todos los
partidos del país en este momento además
también se amenaza con poder llegar
incluso a solicitar la dimisión de la
ministra de Justicia o llegar incluso a
acusaciones constitucionales fue una
medida por otro lado acogida de forma
muy favorable por la asociación Nacional
de presos de la revuelta por los
familiares que venían luchando desde
hace bastantes meses para que el
presidente Gabriel boric cumpliera esta
medida que había tratado de hacer A
través de una ley en el congreso en una
de sus primeras tomas de decisiones en
cuanto llegó a la moneda pero esta ley
no prosperó en el congreso no tuvo los
votos necesarios para lograr la amnistía
de una gran parte de todas las personas
envueltas en delitos o en condenas
durante el estallido social al no
hacerlo así se ha recurrido al indulto
que es una facultad del presidente
establecida por una ley que así lo Norma
y
estudiado caso a caso para ir dando lo
que serían los primeros de estos 12
indultos a los que se añade el de Jorge
mate luna y que podrían ir ampliándose
en próximos meses
en Brasil el presidente Jair bolsonaros
salió este viernes del país con destino
Estados Unidos en un avión de la fuerza
aérea por lo que romperá con la
tradición del traspaso presidencial de
poder antes de su salida hizo un llamado
a sus seguidores para que hagan una dura
oposición al gobierno de Lula da Silva
nuestra corresponsal en Brasil Valeria
sakone con los detalles
el presidente Jair bolsonaro ha dejado
Brasil para instalarse en Florida en los
Estados Unidos durante unos meses para
un período sabático son dos las razones
que le llevan a esa decisión no quería
entregar la banda presidencial a su
rival Luis Ignacio luluda Silva pero
también teme ser preso porque a partir
del uno de enero perderá la inmunidad y
hay varias acusaciones contra él entre
las cuales está divulgar noticias falsas
sobre el covid al asociar la vacuna al
sida poco antes de marcharse a bordo del
avión presidencial bolsonaro hizo su
última conexión en directo desde las
redes sociales y por fin condenó el
intento de ataque terrorista aquí en
Brasilia durante las navidades cuando la
policía encontró un camión bomba cerca
del aeropuerto pero se desmarcó de los
campamentos de bolsonaristas que desde
hace dos meses están protestando frente
a los cuarteles del ejército en varias
ciudades de Brasil contra la victoria de
Lula la reacción a sus palabras de sus
seguidores ha sido contundente hemos
visto a muchos bolsonaristas
decepcionados incluso llorando que han
abandonado estas postaciones en las que
han estado incluso Debajo de la lluvia
en las últimas semanas ahora en Brasil
está todo listo para la investidura de
Lula que será el 1 de enero hay mucha
seguridad aquí mucha policía lo hemos
comprobado hoy en la plaza de los tres
poderes y se espera que todo pueda
proceder de una forma pacífica y sin
violencia
con las últimas noticias desde Brasil
despedimos este informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]